our next guest almost took over the role
of steve in blue's clues i didn't even
know that please welcome justin long
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
we haven't seen each other we we've been
texting and and and audio messages yes
which i don't know how to keep
oh there's a little thing a blue thing
that says keep to the right i mean that
in a condescending way but because it's
hard it's easy to miss it says keep and
but sometimes when you keep messages
like christian you know doggy he gets a
little brother my brother sorry i forgot
we were on a tv show that's right tv
show with people um we're just reuniting
on national television like you do yeah
you know how when
your former love has a host a show and
yeah this is wild well you left me this
audio this audio message and it was so
funny and i meant to try and save it to
play only to realize i don't know how to
do that little blue keep okay thank you
see you learned something new every day
um okay so i was talking with mike
barbiglia the amazing comedian very
funny yes um and we did this movie with
him going the distance and so biggs and
i are just chit-chatting um we're doing
a social piece it wasn't a part of the
show oh and in it i compliment you
and i heard you heard about it well
people sent it to me because it went
everywhere
well it was the most flat it was for you
to be saying how funny i am now first of
all i feel like i have to be really
funny to live up to that type of first
you're so funny i know what do you got
what do you got uh that's it that's what
he said he said uh think about now he's
been talking about how to keep text
messages um
but you think all of us who need i.t are
grateful yeah okay well you're welcome
uh but it it was so flattering i mean
you know i i think of you and i wanted
to say i said it as i was watching it
you're the funny one i mean you are
one of the funniest people i've ever met
everyone who knows this because they
watch your show you know that it's you
go toe-to-toe when you're a kid with
letterman not many people can do that
you're the you're yeah i'll never forget
the laughs yeah we had a lot of laughs
we that's what we did we laughed we left
all the time so much yeah like that was
so much a part of our connection was
that we love funny people yeah we enjoy
laughing at all times i feel like even
when things get dark i laugh harder yes
yeah you can get dark you can which
people don't know on a daytime show
maybe but um you are one of the funniest
darkest darkest funny people yes i have
a dark side yes yeah i don't know if you
know that well tell them something
darkly funny right now something really
like tragically funny
let's get into it oh god but yeah we
laughed a lot and it's it's um
it's funny because i i've been going
back over you know all the time we've
known each other and and what are we
going to talk about i mean this is just
this is very strange it is surreal
surreal i'm so grateful that you would
do this with me oh are you kidding i of
course i'm grateful you wanted me
thanks to you guys for coming
and you know it's funny when we launch
the show you know in the industry
everyone's like who's your first guest
like it's some measuring contest
and um you see what i was doing there
and i was like god i don't where it's
september 2020 we're in a pandemic
people aren't coming out it's the
hardest most difficult time in the world
on a global level everything is at stake
we're in the fourth quarter of the game
of our life now make this funny this is
the challenge you've set yourself up now
so i asked cameron and lucy to come on
as the first guests makes sense because
i thought my professional endeavors are
i hold them so high with them and we've
been through birth life death divorce
marriage kids
you know vacations yeah work yeah poo
what you and poo auntie poo poo that's
cameron diaz yeah
yeah sure
um and so i asked them and i just
thought what about if this year we could
start the show together because i think
relationships in this world are
one of the most universal subjects
everyone
is out there either in love looking for
love looking for relationships but
relationships transcend also the
romantic you know you are working with a
co-worker or you have a best friend or a
parent
we're all in relationships i
love that we've maintained our love
because it i i don't think it'll ever i
know from my end it'll never go anywhere
i'll love you always you know and so i i
i'm glad that we're able to
still have that i mean that i i always
love you
i i will always love you so much
i feel like we've been through so much
together too you know i feel like when
we used to like talk and facetime i was
always like you know i've really grown
up justin like i always wanted to prove
to you
what a different person i was than when
we dated you were the best i mean we had
so much fun no i know but we were you
know
more hedonistic a little more immature
you know we would get together we would
break up you know there was chaos it was
hell of fun fun chaos oh yeah yeah well
it's yeah most hedonism is fun there's
not a lot of bad hedonism
i don't think if you look yes for
hedonism
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah you're doing it wrong then we had a
blast and i i cherish that time i do i i
mean when we first met you were such a
bachelor that you
you had like a i was funny
when we first met you know i was 20 21
yeah you had um an overstuffed trash
compactor
and um holes in your sheet in an outdoor
gym i'm just gonna say
yeah that is true i remember you looking
at me once we had the best night we went
out
and um a night of hedonism and uh and
you said and i put on a hat
do you remember this baseball cap
you're not going to believe the full
circle of this yes you put on a baseball
cap and what did i do well you are one
of the least judgmental people you are
allowed me to be
that you are such a safe person and
thank you never judged and and there was
this one moment you looked at me you
just said i put on this we've been
having fun and i was like oh my cap my
university of texas shout out i have
nothing to do with them but it was a
universe yes you t
yeah go longhorn yeah i put it on and
you and you just went
nope
don't understand
what do you mean
no baseball cats
all right well i can do this all these
other things are so fun we were getting
along like i've never gotten along with
anyone yeah and so okay i don't have to
wear a baseball cap i'll wear a
propeller beanie instead a less
embarrassing thing do you know what's so
funny yeah i wear baseball caps now
full circle i get it yeah
they're i get it yes they're baseball
caps and we had so many nicknames for
each other yes what i can't text you
anymore because i've got you
as 15 different names so that's why i
was freaking out trying to text you back
and it wouldn't go through because
you're under too many contacts because
we had too many names we i have you on
yeah yes that is true uh but uh the
first name i remember was uh for years i
knew you was
you know what i'm gonna say no uh i was
chuckles
yes yes yes the playboy night yes oh we
all went to the playboy mansion yes this
is a by the way hedonism oh there you go
guess where hedonism is living its best
life or what yeah it was it was
all these days yeah i know i know but
i'm telling you why was the 80s and 90s
so good i know well
yes i know to remember oh no it's all
right uh yeah we met at the well we met
before we said we all went our sent
friend sam rockwell who won an academy
award and he was the lead in charlie's
angels
he's the villain
and my casting director best friend and
i were obsessed with him so we were like
christine justine let's make him the
lead in this movie and we always knew
that he was the most talented most
dynamic actor and finally he won his
academy yeah so deserved long deserved
um but we had just done
galaxy quest and we've done a play so i
got to sam and i became really good
friends and one night he said hey you
want to go out i'm going to meet my some
friends you got to be drew you got to
meet drew
and and he said um and i said yeah you
know i loved you i was uh at 21. i was
just out to la for the first time and
just getting out of your diapers getting
out of diapers i was just uh completing
puberty almost in pity puberty and i
thought you know what that you you were
a late bloomer though i was sort of
yeah he was a labeler yes let's talk
about that let's unpack that yeah thank
you and yet you still look like
really young wow
you i mean that compliment okay okay i
need that complimentary you do like in
your intro the tidbit about blues clues
i'm like of course like you still look
like hey everyone hey blue yeah i'm like
it's gonna where as you age with a young
face it's not a great but you look so i
was we were all backstage you like so
really oh my god thank you thank you so
much to me you know what i've done to
myself so i'm just hanging off that's
amazing
i know considering kind of
i think it's all going to turn a corner
in like a matter of a day that's what i
feel like one day it's just going to be
like
you know
it's really true like it's like the
bad it is held together
uh wait what was your nickname well why
not we gave each other play because we
were going to the playboy mansion so we
gave each other playboy names right we
thought we'd like really like embrace
the the
the night out at the playboy mansion you
were i can't believe you don't remember
this what was it
whiskey
guess yes whiskey bargain yeah great you
got it yeah yeah
oh my gosh game nights yes oh god i was
a nut case i used to like just drink and
be
[Applause]
i was like guy like i wasn't true
it was wild i remember playing with with
quentin tarantino oh my god we played
with clinton yeah uh catchphrase
oh yeah i don't know it was it was uh oh
god uh apples tables was it applesauce
it could have been apples to apples it
was that cranial cradium yes and he was
going to um here's what it is and he was
all juiced up and wild and
yes
i
i
i live for that by the way
uh that is the greatest compliment to
just a genuine drew spit take the best
you still have it in there sorry oh
finally
but
if you know quentin tarantino who is a
genius but he is like you know
fully loaded yeah he's a person who like
you know
everything is like on 20. yes yeah the
stakes are so high and it's like it's a
game you know but we would get uh we had
the best yeah game nights
[Music]
you